last night the final german troops
stationed in afghanistan left the
country
later this week the withdrawal of u.s
troops is expected to be completed
ending a mission that began almost two
decades ago a mission that became
america's longest war
it was the 9 11 terror attacks in the
u.s in 2001 that prompted the u.s led
mission in afghanistan
the target the taliban which controlled
afghanistan at the time
and had given the 911 terrorists a place
to plot
their attacks two trillion dollars later
and countless casualties
among afghan civilians and alliance
forces
can anyone claim mission accomplished
as the withdrawal ends the taliban is
reclaiming
territory quickly the top u.s general
predicted a civil war could erupt within
months
and that could spell doom for the
fragile progress
that was achieved under the protective
umbrella of an alliance
that is now going home
for peter schwedick afghanistan is a
home away from home
for more than 30 years he and his wife
anna marie have been aid workers there
teaching children how to read and write
and do maths both are disappointed with
the international community's
achievements
civilian reconstruction should have
begun at the administrative level
they should have put an administration
in place and kept a close eye on what
they did with all the funding
none of that was checked they just kept
throwing money at it and when things
didn't work out they just threw more
club
say children still don't learn enough at
school
partly because international partners
made mistakes
on an organizational level too
see
despite debate about whether the
intervention of the international
community was worthwhile
there have been marked improvements
especially in education
unesco say the number of kids enrolling
in schools has risen clearly
but the education gap between rural and
urban areas remains
there has been considerable progress at
primary school level
it's estimated that half of all afghans
can now read and write
that was different 20 years ago
the same goes for educating girls in the
1990s under the taliban they got no
education
at all women were completely oppressed
under the taliban their situation
remains precarious
but they have gained some rights they
can vote
join political movements and go into
business
but state-level corruption remains
endemic transparency international ranks
afghanistan
as one of the world's most corrupt
countries one reason why aid money
doesn't always reach its intended
destination
we have to acknowledge that the
international community was not capable
of laying down rules on how the money
was to be spent
they never got around to introducing
good governance or tackling corruption
the security situation remains dramatic
now the taliban is pushing to get back
into power
it already has half the country under
its control
that's why anna marie and peter shritik
expect the situation in afghanistan to
stay
just as it's always been extremely
unstable
i don't see any long-term peace
unless the government reconciles with
the taliban
and tries to get the country sorted out
itself
still the couple plan to go back again
soon
they say the people need their help now
more than ever
my first guest tonight is dr eleanor
cyno the country director for
afghanistan at the german think tank the
conrad
adenauer foundation she joins me from
here in berlin it's good to have you
on the day i want to start by getting
your opinion
on this we've been hearing all day from
the german military that this
was a mission accomplished in
afghanistan do you agree
well i think we don't have accomplished
all of our goals and expectations and
we have stayed below our expectations in
many points
and we just heard about we don't have
security for the afghans in the country
we don't have basic infrastructure in
kabul we have only a few hours of water
and electricity a day
and corruption fighting has not been
successful
so in many points we have not
accomplished i understand that you are
planning to return to kabul
in july does that trip now take on more
risks and dangers for you personally
now that u.s and nato forces have
withdrawn yes of course it
it takes more risk and also it's
completely unpredictable
about the next weeks and months that
what we will see
and my security setup of course is much
more safer than
many afghans have in kabul or in
afghanistan
but it's unpredictable for all of us and
we don't know
under what risks and under what
conditions i will return to kabul
what do you say when you're back in
kabul
if afghans come up to you and say
germany the u.s have abandoned us what's
your response
well i say to them that i have always
said
to my afghan partners and networks i
have always said
you don't have to wait you cannot wait
for an external savior
and an afghan solution a peaceful
solution can only come from inside from
the afghans themselves
and i can only call on the international
community also to place
confidence in the afghans that they can
reach a peaceful settlement but of
course there is no guarantee of success
yeah and what's your feeling from the
the afghans that you talk with
in the country i mean is there any
possibility that a peaceful
resolution can be found with the taliban
well currently the mood is really
shifting and people become much more
pessimistic
and and i can really feel the tension
growing day by day and also the
anxieties
increasing day by day and the problem
it's not only the taliban
there's many armed groups in the country
and many conflict parties
to the conflict and this is the
difficult task
of getting a negotiated settlement where
all of the interests the different
interests
are kind of represented and also
balanced
and so i think the taliban yes they are
now the dominating force
but there are many armed groups and now
we see in re-arming of militias in the
country what i
find quite worrying and that has to
really spell
doom for the future of women's rights in
the country
or does it yes it's of course it's
women's rights it's human rights it's
also
the freedom of media the freedom of
press the freedom of expression
so um i see particularly when we when we
talk about women rights and education
i see more the danger to an islamization
of education of the public life of
public media
and this is the main threat that i see
if we have a government in the future
with the taliban
eleanor zainer from the conrad adenauer
foundation dr santa we appreciate your
time tonight we wish you all the best
on your upcoming trip to kabul stay safe
thank you